incoming bonus content
i remember fever pitch story i remember
you
literally hurting your back
falling off the green monster
i did in boston you came down it's in
the movie you went landon you were like
ah i landed on my tailbone yes that i
had cracked during charlie's angels two
days and you had to run all the way
through fenway park to me and you were
just so out of breath of the third take
you were like
okay i remember another story i remember
flying on an airplane and we were flying
to the the the game game seven of the
world series the red sox and it was in
st louis
and i was like we were terrified but we
were gonna get to shoot on the fox
sports cameras the ending of our film if
they won they were gonna let us run down
to home plate and do a 360 kiss had the
cameras it was a fox broadcast yeah and
we were making a fox movie so we said
can we borrow a couple cameras while
we're so we because they're like you
can't bring your movie cameras to the
game yeah and we said just on one
condition you can't show that jimmy and
drew at the game on your broadcast
because that won't make any sense we're
making a movie and doing cut to we're
making out on the dugout or something
which and aired on the world series and
everyone's like what
are they dating what's going on oh and
my boyfriend at the time didn't know
and didn't know we were doing that aaron
he's like hey got a great text in the
strokes and on tour and i couldn't talk
to him because it was it was before cell
phones yeah and i hadn't got to him and
he was like what's going on
and i was like oh god it's part of the
movie yeah the best thing ever we had so
much fun
and that was a little bit extra for you
[Music]
you